il ya beaucoup moins d'intérêt de toute
façon à suivre ce qui se passe dans les
églises les exécutifs et les parlements
locaux municipaux etc
parce que l'action s'il ya énormément
technocrates ise c'est à dire que de
plus en plus on nous fait passer ce
qu'ils étaient avant des débats
politiques sur que faire que faire de
notre commune que faire de notre région
que faire de notre département est aussi
que faire de notre pays d'ailleurs pour
finalement un débat technique qui est
quelle est la bonne réforme à mettre en
oeuvre pour mettre en place ce bon plan
d'économies qui nous a été dicté par les
bonnes instance technocratique elle même
inspirée par le sz un présage de
bruxelles et donc finalement le suspense
le suspense a raconté l'intérêt a
raconté cette histoire là il a
complètement disparu parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a plus aucune
surprise ces décisions sont souvent
connues d'avancé
et d'ailleurs les élus s'en remettent
eux mêmes à des supras entité que ce
soit les intercommunalités par exemple
ou tout un tas de comités techniques à
qui on délègue finalement la décision
démocratique donc la démocratie c'est
intéressant c'est palpitant c'est bien
raconté
mais encore faut-il qui en est une et
actuellement il y en a pas vraiment
c'est pour ça que les journalistes comme
tout le monde d'ailleurs essayé de
chercher de l'intérêt dans ces
régionales de façon beaucoup plus
indirectes c'est-à-dire quel impact pour
le futur et là je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est à dire qu'en réalité ces
régionales n'ont été traitées que sous
l'angle de quel impact pour la
présidentielle qui reste en fait est de
plus en plus le scrutin qui peut
vraiment en tout cas dont on a
l'impression que ça peut vraiment tout
changer parce que là effectivement il ya
de grandes orientations politiques qui
s'affrontent mais sur les
départementales sur les régionales
qu'elles étaient les grandes
orientations politiques qui
s'affronteraient quels étaient les
grands projets on ne sait pas
[Musique]